Speaker 1: We looked over the last week at an
incredible viral interview where Trump lawyer Joe
Tacopina went on MSNBC and was interviewed by Ari
MELBER and lunged for papers, tried to lunge and
take papers from Ari MELBER, whose hand another
Trump lawyer has gone on MSNBC. And it went
just as poorly, if not worse, Instant collapse
from Drew Findling. Drew Findling is a criminal
defense attorney. He's really known like as a hip
hop attorney because he has represented a number
of well-known hip hop musicians. Doesn't make
him any better or worse of an attorney. It's an
interesting thing that Trump has gone with someone
who is known really as as a hip hop attorney.
He went on MSNBC. Ari MELBER asked him
questions. It really doesn't go well
for Findling. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Same level of passion,
but you're not the judge or the jury in this
case. You're the lawyer. We're talking to you
not for your conclusions without evidence, but
for the evidence you can marshal right now,
I'm giving you the time. If you can't do it
tonight, if you can't give us any arguments,
then we will note that. But let me put up
on the screen again for your rebuttal if
you want to take this time.
Speaker 1: And importantly,
I should mention this is a defense
attorney for Trump in the Georgia case,
which I believe is potentially the strongest one.
Speaker 2: Election fraud in Georgia. If you
request or attempt to cause another
person to engage in voter fraud,
that's criminal solicitation. If you conspire
or agree with another to commit a violation,
that is another Georgia statute. Those are both
felonies. Those are just two. And there are,
as you know, others. Donald Trump, post
December 14th, I'll give you the widest
possible berth that before it's certified. There
are arguments that could be theoretically made
about alternate electors. But post December
14th, he's on tape doing it. We have a new call
we learned about in the last week demanding it.
How is that not soliciting or conspiring fraud?
Yeah. So. So I'm familiar. My team is familiar
with all those statutes. And while I'm looking
at this camera, I can tell you we're incredibly
familiar with those statutes. They aren't new
to us. We do a lot of political cases. Sure,
we are absolutely confident, having looked at
the evidence that our client has not violated
any of those, we're not going to look at it
two dimensionally. We're going to look at it three
dimensional. What did he which he said, fine, and
he's completely innocent. But what did he
mean when he said find votes that don't exist
after certification? What could that possibly
mean other than find votes that don't exist?
Well, I will I will say this
and that is that again. Okay.
Looking at the entire 62 minutes,
putting it all in context, there
was nothing illegal said by our client. No.
Speaker 1: That's the best. When Trump said,
I need 11,000 votes, give me a break.
I just want to find 11,780 votes,
which is one more than we have. What did he mean
when he said that? Well, you've got to listen to
the whole call in context. Oh, really? Did he
open the call with everything I'm about to say
is merely a joke? What what could have proceeded
that that would have made that in any way not a
violation of those statutes. And this continued
and. MELBER Just doing everything he can to try to
actually get substance from Drew Findling, that.
Speaker 2: He lost the election and got people
to submit false material to the government and
everywhere else or conspire to do so. And that's a
potential crime. So, Ari, let me tell you, because
what I'm not going to do is I'm not going to be a
hypocrite and I'm not going to be disingenuous.
Speaker 1: Oh, good. Well, then I'm sure
he's going to. That's a nice disclaimer.
Speaker 2: When I talk about prosecutors who I
know very, very well and have great relationships
with. But when I call and say and file something
that they that they went down the political avenue
and that has no place in this case, I'm not going
to turn around and start being political because.
Speaker 1: So understand that this is a case
where the fact this is this is a classic,
particularly for lawyers on TV, where you're
not you're not trying the case on TV, at least
not overtly. If if the facts aren't on your side,
you argue about process. It was political and
it was the wrong venue and it was all targeting
my client unfairly and blah, blah, blah.
Speaker 2: I'm a hypocrite for everything
that I put in 50 pages. So, respectfully,
I appreciate you bringing that up and I
appreciate you appreciate it out. I do appreciate
being on the show. But I got to tell you, Drew,
I'm not going political. I got to tell you, I'm
not going to be giving you time and I'll give your
colleagues time and we'll have you back. But it is
not accurate. Absolutely. But this is a case about
trying to steal an election. Ascertaining the
facts of that is not, quote unquote, political.
It is the bleeding, the beating heart of the
center of this case because Donald Trump lied
about it. And it seems today that you're in a you
have an inability to acknowledge that he lost the
state of Georgia, which is odd because, you know,
he lost the state of Georgia. We all know that.
I don't have an inability to do anything. I
have the ability to tell you what I think was
in the scope of the questions that I'll answer
regarding the filing of 50 pages motion and 400
pages of exhibits. And we got concerns. I think
you agree we the special purpose grand jury,
nothing. Right. Understood. And
but nothing in that is political
from our vantage point that we call out.
Speaker 1: He's not going to do anything
political at all in terms of answering
inconvenient questions. But then when they
stuff this filing full of 400 pages of, quote,
concerns that are riddled with political concerns,
that's not political according to him. If you're
having trouble following this, I don't blame you.
Speaker 2: For being political. So I'm not going
to be disingenuous and start being political. I'm
going to talk about the facts that are contained
in there. Yeah, right. And I'm not going to be
put in a position where I have to make one claim
or another claim. I am. As you know, you pointed
out my relationship to the bar, deeply committed
to my profession and deeply committed. All right.
Speaker 1: So now he's saying he really is
committed to being a lawyer. Wow. You know,
I thought that Trump really thought they had
Trump dead to rights. By the way, the look on Ari
MELBER, his face here in this still shots kind of
says everything says it says it all I Trump seems
like he's super guilty he seems guilty as hell
but did you know his lawyer is really committed
to the practice of law? Oh, he is. Oh, well, then
it must be not guilty. I guess this is a nonsense
interview, and I don't really even know whether.
So I guess MSNBC wants to do these interviews
because they sort of always go like this, and it's
very cartoonish. I guess the lawyers want to do
the interviews because they know probably that
Trump doesn't always pay his lawyers. And so if
they can get some publicity out of it, then maybe
they can make money on the back end from other
people hiring them. I don't really know. But they
come together and it just instantly implodes. And
so the continued interviews with Trump, Trump's
lawyers are not going particularly well and then
closing out our review of the last 24 hours. It
also not going particularly well for Donald Trump,